despite joe biden's repeated insistence
that americans who have already taken
the covid vaccine get a booster shot the
fda just voted 16 to 3 to reject booster
shots for the general public
here it is i've got it here is the news
report of the vote this is from my yahoo
it's from the independent through yahoo
it's all i don't want to be accused of
spreading misinformation okay
now even if the vaccine peddlers
convince the fda to reverse its decision
the vote has seriously undermined the
prevailing public health narrative
safe and effective the vaccines are so
effective that they require a booster
shot and so safe that the fda won't
approve the booster shot for most people
meanwhile a fake january 6th reunion and
a censored flood of foreigners across
our southern border reminds american
patriots that things are not always as
they appear i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from charles troopy
who says when nicki minaj becomes the
modern day john locke it's official time
to get the earth
time to stop the earth i need to get off
that is not fair i actually don't think
that's fair at all nicki minaj makes
much much more sense than john locke
stop thinking like a liberal nicki minaj
makes a whole lot more sense
than the vaunted mr locke
when you
want to protect
your data when you want to protect your
identity in this crazy world of ours i
would strongly recommend you check out
expressvpn i want you to think about
those things you look at online you know
you go you open up your internet browser
maybe you open up the incognito browser
you know and you type in those websites
you don't want anyone to see
you know i'm talking about dailywire.com
okay you're not some of those
conservative websites they could get you
in trouble mister
to keep your data private i would
strongly recommend you check out
expressvpn you know i mean i'm making a
joke about if you're looking at naughty
things on the internet but increasingly
even if you're looking at perfectly
wholesome things perfectly ordinary
things that are politically incorrect
that could pose a real problem for you
because there are a lot of data brokers
out there their whole business is to buy
and sell your data
worst part is
they don't have to tell you who they're
selling it to they don't need to get
your consent use expressvpn it's super
easy okay
data harvesters use your ip address
to uniquely identify you and your
location when i use expressvpn i click
the button expressvpn goes on it's very
simple on my phone and on my computer
and then i don't need to worry about it
if you're like me and you believe your
data is your business secure it with the
number one rated vpn on the market
that's expressvpn.com michael get three
extra months for free that's
expressvpn.com michael to learn more
i love this vote from the fda i
absolutely love it it is my favorite
news story in a very long time because
it is one
aspect of the liberal establishment
slightly breaking in any way from the
rest of the liberal establishment right
the fda the agency breaking from the
dominant narrative that the vaccines are
totally 100 000 safe and there's no
question whatsoever about any safety and
they're super duper effective and
they're so great that you need
multiple booster shots
the
establishment i don't know what term to
use the blob the ruling class the regime
they have done everything they can
to prevent anyone from questioning the
narrative whatsoever i'll give you an
example of this i got a notification on
my instagram over the weekend that gina
carano had had tagged me in an instagram
story
he said oh that's great you know gina
carano this terrific movie tv star now
is doing a movie with the daily wire so
i look and it was just a little video of
me making fun of dr fauci i wasn't
really making any claims and no
scientific or political claims in there
i was just kind of doing my deck to
fouchy voice and making fun of what a
jerky is right so that's all that it was
and it was her posting and saying like
ha ha this is funny
so i tried to repost it but i couldn't
because there was a big warning label on
this video of me making fun of fauci's
voice and it said quote for covet
information you've got to go to the blah
blah blah blah blah i said well i'm not
i'm not expressing any covet information
here i'm just making fun of this jerk in
the public health establishment
so okay i go i kind of do a work around
i go into my inbox i find the story i
share it to my my
own page and then
a few hours later
i went back to look at it i wanted to
see how many people had seen it you get
these you get these analytics from
instagram so i looked
and i had shared two things to instagram
at the very same time the first thing i
shared had been seen by a little over 8
000 people
that that had come from a
very small
account then i shared gina's story
that had been seen by 58 people that is
an impossibly small number what it says
to me is something we probably all
inferred for a long time which is that
if you you see something on instagram
with that warning label covid
misinformation it's just not being sure
it's being shared to so very few people
that for all intents and purposes it's
not going up and the
oligarchy the
in this case using
big tech as a proxy
is going is willing to do that even on
jokes even on jokes about the high
priests of
the regime then also on instagram
try searching for
natural immunity as a hashtag
so we we all know natural immunity is a
thing by the way i don't want to be
accused of spreading misinformation even
the public health establishment even dr
fauci is acknowledging there is such a
thing as natural immunity but it's taken
a very long time for them to do that and
they're really trying to downplay it if
you search natural immunity on instagram
it won't come up the nearest thing is
someone who wrote hashtag natural
immunity with a middle finger emoji
because big tech
is censoring this stuff they don't want
any of this information getting out okay
well
explain to me then
why it is
that the fda is holding off on booster
shots for americans
before you say it let me i want to cut
off the liberal critics at their knees
they'll probably say well no michael
it's just a technical issue you see
because they didn't have enough data and
what don't worry the next time he goes
up for a vote it's going to pass and
this okay i'm not asking about any of
that i'm not asking about any of the
scientific data here i'm asking why if
it is so obviously common sense that the
vaccine is 100 safe and 100 effective
why the fda wouldn't approve it for
everybody
obviously because they had questions
about the safety of the vaccine for
people under 65 for the vast majority of
americans
and as for the effectiveness the very
fact that you need the booster shot
shows you that the vaccine is much less
effective than we were told that it is
some of us knew this from the beginning
and we just continued to live our lives
despite the wuflu in spite of the
chinese cough
there's a new study out about this not
about the effectiveness of vaccines or
the virulence of the virus but about how
people reacted to it
this is going to be a really shocking
study a study that shows that
conservatives republicans and christians
fared much better in terms of their
mental health in terms of their stress
and anxiety during the covid epidemic
especially the early days
then did the democrats and the liberals
and the atheists now these are distinct
categories but there's obviously a lot
of overlap
if you're
conservative you're also likely to be
republican you're also likely to be
christian if you're
a lib you're also likely to be a
democrat you're also likely to be an
atheist i mean it's a lot of
a lot of overlap here and here's what
the study showed quote
this study demonstrates that religion
protected mental health but constrained
support for crisis response during the
crucial early days of the covet 19
pandemic data from a national
probability by a sample of the u.s
population show that highly religious
individuals and evangelicals suffered
less distress in march 2020 they were
also less likely to see the coronavirus
outbreak as a crisis and less likely to
support public health restrictions to
limit the spread of the virus the
conservative politicization of religion
in the united states whatever that means
can help explain why religious americans
and evangelicals in particular
experienced less distress and were less
likely to back public health efforts to
contain the virus we conclude that
religion can be a source of comfort and
strength in times of crisis but at least
in the case of this pandemic it can also
undercut efforts to end the root causes
of suffering so i'm going to pause it
right there because i totally agree with
half of this survey i agree with the
thing that the survey observed namely
that stress levels were lower in people
who aren't atheist libs
the stress levels were lower at people
who are conservative christians
the part i'm going to disagree with is
that this undercuts the way to solve the
pandemic it didn't undercut anything
i know that people are trying to make us
forget this now they're trying to
pretend that america never locked down
and we never wore masks and we never did
any of this but we did we did everything
that these idiots told us to do
we we slowed the spread for 15 days we
all wore the stupid masks when we had to
we all locked down we all shut down our
businesses we all locked ourselves up in
our homes at least to some degree
for
now going on a year and a half more than
a year and a half
for no reason
because it didn't work
it didn't work at all now
the the revisionist history of this is
oh we just couldn't get people to wear
the masks we did people did wear the
masks even i hated the stupid mask but i
would wear it in certain circumstances
on airplanes or whenever they forced me
to
okay we did it and it didn't work that
well and by the way everyone was living
their life as though this had a fifty
percent mortality rate and it didn't the
vast fast fastest says that vast
majority of people
were perfectly fine with coronavirus so
rather than say look religion's a good
source of comfort it keeps down your
stress levels but it also can can
undermine the the efforts that we need
to stop the pandemic it also makes
people too complacent no it doesn't we
were right we were right coronavirus for
the vast majority of people is just not
a big deal we were right we should just
live our lives despite the very real
possibility of death and in the case of
coronavirus the very very low
possibility of death
this drives me nuts jonathan height did
this
a few years ago when he he came out and
gave a big ted talk about how the left
under doesn't understand the right but
the right understands the left and he
described all of these various metrics
by which the various political groups
can try to make sense of one another and
the conclusion that he drew was or
rather the conclusion
from the data was that the conservatives
understand the liberals but the liberals
don't understand the conservatives and
then the political conclusion he drew
was
and that's why we just need both sides
man it's like no that's not why we just
need both sides the conservatives
understand everything and the libs only
understand about half of everything and
so actually maybe you should defer to
the conservatives because they're more
correct but we're not allowed to say
that because because we have to
say
that both sides are exactly the same or
something it's not true we were right
the libs were wrong period okay they
make us out to be the crazies
the the ruling class of this country
makes the right wing out to be the
crazies in fact as this
survey as this study on stress shows
the libs are much likely
much more likely to be the crazies
and the libs are now so crazy they're so
uh tilting at windmills they're so
hunting for phantoms and ghosts that
they're now holding their own
insurrection parties to try to bait and
catch people
to which nobody shows up
you know in this wild crazy world with a
wild crazy economy you really ought to
check out acre gold when things are
going crazy in the economy it's very
important that you can hedge your bets
against inflation one great way to do
that is with physical gold now i know
what you're thinking michael
what michael i can't invest in physical
gold it's too expensive no calm down
michael there's no way yes you can you
can
with acre gold acre gold has figured out
this ingenious way to start investing in
physical gold without coming out of
pocket all at once
you subscribe to their gold bars when
your gold stash reaches the price of
their gold bars they will discreetly
ship physical acre gold to your door
they've got a new hundred dollar a month
uh subscription to a five gram gold bar
it's really really great stuff go check
it out right now visit
getacregold.com start investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
that url because acres giving away a
gold bar free gold to qualify for the
giveaway tweeter post why you should be
the recipient and mention at get
underscore acre that's getacre
getacregold.com
knowles thank you acre gold for
supporting the show
there was a justice for january 6th
rally
this weekend this was a rally in
washington dc and it was to avenge the
terrible injustices done at january 6th
you know and it was supposed to be for
all the right wingers to show up and
demand that trump be reinstated or
something like that
except
no conservatives very very few if any
conservatives
showed up
do you know who showed up
the press the media showed up
and
feds
law enforcement officials some of whom
were dressed up like they were in really
military gear
could have used them in kandahar or
could have used them in kabul
and then the other ones were were
undercover
the whole thing was a was an op the
whole thing was fake
i don't know that there were any actual
pro-trump right-wing conservative or
anything to call them i don't know that
any of those people were actually there
there was a photo that went viral it's
so funny
someone just posted this with the
caption you know look at these fed boys
basically so it's a group of of men
standing next to a gadsden flag don't
tread on me
and they stick out like a sore thumb
okay the term for for people like this
is glowies this is the online slang
glowy's meaning federal agents who are
trying to pose as whatever
insurrectionists terrorists criminals
but they stick out like a sore thumb
they glow in the dark okay so these guys
are all wearing
not quite matching but almost matching
clothing
tight jean shorts
all of which have the almost all of
which have the cuff rolled up at the
bottom
all
similar style shirts without any labels
on them all wearing the same watch a
non-apple smart watch looks like a
garment all wearing
basically the same sunglasses if not
exactly the same sunglasses one of them
went to the trouble of getting a fascist
haircut you know it's really thin on the
side and then a little longer on top but
he didn't get it early enough like
clearly he went down to the pentagon
barber that afternoon because the
because that part of his hair that had
been shaved off is is extremely white
compared to the rest of his skin so it
was a very recent haircut and they're
all kind of checking around checking
their six a lot of situational awareness
not one of them has any tattoos not one
of them is wearing a trump shirt or
anything like that
it's pathetic now i guess there look
there's a chance that these are
legitimate
protesters oh they're wearing uh
black dress socks
some of which are a little bit short but
the one guy like forgot to change over
at langley so it's a little bit longer
and they've all got something sticking
out of their pocket presumably some kind
of firearm if it's not a fire and by the
way it's illegal to have have that
firearm there uh
if it's not i i believe it's illegal i
think they're on on grounds where that
would be illegal if
they're not carrying that so presumably
they're law enforcement if not it sure
looks like one
all matching it's just so
so fake i it gives me the only thing
that really gives me hope here in this
picture is how incompetent they are by
the way here's my further evidence
because i don't want to seem like i'm a
conspiracy theorist so there were we're
getting uh conflicting reports but there
were as many as four arrests made during
the rally so just four arrests made
during the rally and
they may very well all have been arrests
of law enforcement people because we
have video of one of the arrests and you
can actually see
in the video of the arrest the guy who's
being arrested pulls out his badge
so he's pulling out a badge and the rest
the rest of law enforcement is there and
they're you know kind of dragging him
and then they they
drag him off and it's
very very silly and very very fake
authenticity is a very difficult thing
to fake okay
so
this is showing as i think many of us
would have inferred from some of the
january 6 stuff that
the federal government
has an interest in trying to provoke
these sorts of incidents i mean this is
why at this i'm not saying the ku klux
klan doesn't exist
i'm just saying it's about 97 fbi agents
or 99 fbi agents i mean these
it's it's all
it would seem to me just a kind of
farce it's all play acting okay
authenticity is very hard to fake though
even beyond the silly you know
rally rally for january 6th hey do any
of you fellow dissidents want to commit
acts of domestic terrorism
hey hey come on do it do it it's like
poking the guy with a stick but you'll
see this in in regular politics too i
saw two campaign ads over the weekend
that i think will show you
the distinction we're talking about here
the first one was from the much-maligned
congresswoman marjorie taylor green
march retailer green
uh airs this ad to convince people of
her toughness on socialism
nancy pelosi is sneaking the green new
deal into the 3.5 trillion dollar budget
and in 2022 i'm going to blow away the
democrat socialist agenda
[Music]
[Music]
go to the website below and sign up to
win my 50 caliber gun before joe biden
bans it
okay i love this commercial okay and the
whole knock on marge retailer green
right she's kooky
she's crazy she's extreme and then she
does this this commercial where she's
there with a bear at 50 cow and she
blows up a toyota prius
that says socialism on it and i think
she really blew it up i mean i think all
those various angles were of the car
actually exploding in the middle of a
field
and she says go to this website and you
can win my gun
okay
now
i think that's a pretty effective ad
and i think she's pretty popular in our
district so i think it's obviously
working compare that to georgia governor
brian kemp
who has
had some problems with the conservative
base specifically with how he handled
the various shenanigans around the 2020
presidential election
kemp
tries to make almost the exact same ad
but take a listen let me know if you
think it's as persuasive
i'm brian kemp i'm so conservative
[Music]
[Applause]
i blow up government spending
i own guns
that no one's taken away
my chainsaw's ready to rip up some
regulations
i got a big truck
just in case i need to round up criminal
illegals and take them home myself
yep i just said that
i'm brian kemp if you want a politically
incorrect conservative that's me i don't
think the cringe is ever gonna leave my
face you know how when you were a kid
and your mother said don't cross your
eyes they'll get stuck that way that's
what's gonna happen to the cringing
that's happening on my face right now
from from watching that commercial
brian kemp has to open up with this with
this phrase three words
i'm so conservative
right you'll notice marjorie green
doesn't open up with i'm so conservative
because people know
okay that lady she had a big sign that
said transgenderism is fake or some
version of that outside of her
congressional office which is right
across the street from some huge
pro-trans activist okay right across the
the uh hallway so she's
she lays it all on the table okay she
doesn't need to say i'm margerating i'm
so conservative so brian kemp does
and says i blow up government spending
but he didn't blow up government
spending govern something exploded
behind him but but notice he didn't
shoot it he would oh gosh he wouldn't
want to be caught firing a gun that
could be misinterpreted by people right
so they both blow something up but with
brian kemp it just happens behind him
with marjorie green she pulls the bear
at 50 cal then he says i've got my guns
that nobody's taken away again but you
see he'll hold the gun then he'll blow
something up then he'll hold the gun but
he certainly won't shoot the gun then he
moves on he says and i've got this big
truck you know it's like a saturday
night live parody of a conservative
commercial because i've got this big
truck in case i need to round up any
criminal illegals
listen to that phrase let that sink in
criminal illegal
a little redundant wouldn't you say
those words mean the same it's like yeah
if i in case i need to round up any
illegal illegals but what he's doing
here it's a very specific wording he's
not saying he's going to round up all
the illegals
he's going to round up only the illegals
who are committing additional crimes who
are here in the united states which of
course he's not going to do then he says
i've got this chainsaw
to rip up regulation you know this kind
of 90s and 2000s just like we need to
privatize everything and that's going to
lead to a conservative country
i'm sorry and then after he said the
illegal line what did he say he said
yeah i really said that
yeah i'm really impressed with myself
because hey i know how out there that
was yeah if you want a politically
incorrect governor vote for me now look
i'm not making any
comment about the efficacy of marjorie
green or brian kemp in office i'm not
making any point on their record i'm
making a point on authenticity
marjorie greene
really is who she says she is
brian kemp is not
he is playing a role he's playing this
rowdy rough tough conservative but it's
not it's not real some some operative in
washington dc wrote that commercial and
didn't do a very good job about it and i
think what we're seeing right now with
what happened at the the fake january
6th rally and what's going on right now
with the public health narrative
collapsing we are now seeing more
clearly than perhaps ever before
the stark difference between the
appearances
and the realities of our political
situation
ben is coming up he's gonna be talking
about how the border is wide open we're
gonna be talking about that in just a
second so go check out ben's show for
sure and we'll be right back with a lot
more
welcome back to the show
something i have noticed about the
difference between the right and the
left
is that
the left wants the appearance of the
thing without the thing itself and the
right wants the real thing wants the
real reality
and this is something we talked about in
the early early days of this show and we
haven't talked about it a lot recently
but i mean years ago this this was a
point i really like to focus on
the left likes
decaf coffee you know the left likes
impossible burgers meatless hamburgers
the left likes those things the left
likes
to call things marriage that are not
really marriage the left likes to call
things nations that are not really
nations the left likes the the
appearance like the form of the thing
but they don't want the actual substance
of the stuff and this is why i think
this this focus on authenticity
does
to a great degree matter
when we're when we're trying to figure
out political candidates or political
campaigns or our political system is it
the real thing or is it just the
appearance of the thing when the left
talks about our democracy they don't
actually like our democracy they hate
democracy in texas that pass that
pro-life law they hate democracy that
elected donald trump at least in 2016
they hate that aspect of our democracy
what they really like is their liberal
rule
they want the appearance of democracy
but they don't actually want democracy i
mean right now
the
the amount of focus they have put into
locking down
washington dc from patriotic americans
is is much more intense than the focus
they put on locking down kabul against
terrorists right because they've got
they want to protect the semblance of
our democracy without permitting real
participation in that democracy for
years they talked about how widespread
mail-in voting was a grave threat to
election integrity in this country and
the right to vote now that they're in
power and they think they can
get a fast one by us they're pushing
that entirely all in the name of our
democracy and then
probably the the most obvious attack
they've made on our democracy is that
they are flooding the country with
foreign nationals whom they are already
promising to give
amnesty to and put on a path to
citizenship so that they can vote and we
the people have absolutely no say in
that and every single illegal alien who
comes into this country and is put on a
path to citizenship
takes away
one vote from an american
every single one
every sin and how many we have what
11 million 20 million how many illegal
aliens are there in this country maybe
more than that and it is
it's not just as though this is a
persistent problem that keeps on and
keeps on it keeps on right now we are
seeing a flood of the illegal aliens
come across the country fox news got to
give them credit they had a drone that
was flying over the rio grande to show
this flood this unceasing flood of
foreign nationals pouring into our
country the faa
grounded the drone why because of the
fears
of the
uh drone that the drone was going to
harm the illegal aliens or something
like that
no it's because they didn't want the
press to cover this incident so then fox
news later went up in a chopper and
started covering what went down
this is a wild situation to see from the
air we reported earlier that the faa
grounded our fox news drones we cannot
fly those well the troopers with texas
dps are kind enough to let us go up in
their helicopter with them to get a look
at the situation at this bridge right
now and they are waiting underneath the
international bridge waiting to be
processed by border patrol look at the
mass of people down there this time two
days ago there were just over 4 000
people there are now upwards of 11 000.
we are talking nearly a tripling of the
numbers in just 48 hours or so you can
get a real good perspective from the air
right here of how many people are
constantly streaming
so
uh
11 000 people waiting to be processed
what do we mean by process do we mean
that the border patrol will say no i'm
sorry you're not an american citizen
you've got to go home no no what it
means is they're going to come in
we're not going to know if they have
covet or not
for a lot of these people okay they're
going to come in they're going to be
given a court date they're going to be
released into the interior of the
country they're not going to show up for
their court date and then they're going
to be put on a path to citizenship the
minutes that the democrats have the
political capital to do it
being processed is putting them on the
very first step of their path to
citizenship
which is inevitable once the democrats
have enough political power to do it
that's what's going on right now
and we're not allowed to say boo about
it
and and don't forget
for a very long time the republican
party was basically fine with that
the argument was
not between more immigration or less
immigration but between more immigration
that that is mostly illegal or more
immigration that is mostly legal but no
one it's a it's a fake
debate
it's what we talk about all the time the
court jester conservatives who
pretend to to put up some opposition but
in fact that the only purpose they serve
is to legitimize the liberal ruling
class
they play their little part and they say
yes we're we're kind of slightly
opposing the liberal agenda but actually
their their effect is to support it
that's what we're seeing but now i think
people are finally saying once again you
know i think we may have too many
immigrants coming into this country it's
not that we hate the immigrants it's not
that we're racist or xenophobic it's
just that you know we're taking in
millions and millions of foreign
nationals a year so much more than
anyone anyone else in the world and the
movement of immigrants into the united
states over the last 60 years is the
largest movement of human beings in
recorded history and actually our
country is kind of collapsing and our
internal cohesion is falling important
and we're actually discouraging
assimilation now so maybe just
we got to cool it a little bit i'm not
saying no immigrants ever again but
maybe we got to drastically reduce
the number of immigrants coming into
this country
only now after years and years of a fake
debate
are we seeing
some conservatives stand up and say you
know we've got to really
stop this we've got to slow this down
significantly jd vance made a good point
on this jd vance is the he's the author
of hillbilly elegy
he he is now running for senate in ohio
jd vance just posted the picture of this
he said send in the marines
of course we should
of course we should send in the marines
if we
are not willing to use our military to
stop a flood of foreigners from
illegally pouring over our border i
think there's a word for that isn't it
isn't there
if we're not willing to use our military
to stop that to defend the american
homeland
what do we have a military for oh we
have a military to build schools for
girls in kandahar
right that's that's what we've been
using the military for we have a
military to go hoist the pride flag on
the the embassy in kabul
but we can't use our military to protect
the american homeland
against millions of foreign nationals
who are pouring in
to to force themselves to become
american citizens over time with the
help of the liberal ruling class
send in the marines of course
to stop this but that would undercut
what is now the agenda of border border
patrol and the immigration law
enforcement authorities which is not to
enforce the law
which is to obliterate the law and
release these foreigners into the united
states and the american people don't get
to say boo about it it's enough
to make you wonder how long the country
can persist some people
are looking at this this collapse of any
kind of unity in the country and they're
saying this is a bad thing
oh this is this this isn't good when the
country is being torn apart at the seams
some people are saying maybe it is a
good thing comedian sarah silverman came
out on her podcast and said maybe it's
time for a national divorce
i mean this may be a negative thought
but or maybe a positive one i don't know
but if people aren't getting along
uh like in relationship they break up
you know so like why don't we just
finally just
realize that this
these states aren't working and like
divide up into like two or three
countries
of like usa one and usa two
and they can be usa one like the
conservatives can be usa1 because they
love being number one and that it means
something to them and i'd love to have
that
be theirs they can be usa1
will be usa 2
and we'll be allies
and you'll come over
here and we'll go over there and you
know when you come to certain
many times when you go to a different
country you have to get a vaccine
that's that
and that's that that's that and we'll be
allies you know just like countries that
separate
are famously allies like india and
pakistan you know
we'll just be allies like india and
pakistan well that'll work out well
right
what sarah silverman is suggesting here
is not just being promoted by people on
the left it's being promoted by people
on the right too time for a national
divorce time for a split balkanize the
country rip the country apart that
that'll solve our problems let's just do
it who cares
that is
the
liberal or libertarian answer
to our national problems and as such
it's totally wrong i think there are
three ways
of looking at the national problems the
problems of national cohesion right now
there's the left-wing way which is
dominate the conservatives make them go
along with our way of thinking and run
the country
then there is the sort of libertarianish
way which is hey let's just split
let's just split guys come on if you if
we're not enjoying it anymore let's just
social contract let's just let's just
rip it up and start again
and then there's the
actual conservative way which is no how
about we rule how about we rule the
country and bring bring this country
back into line when we ruled the country
things were relatively better and so
let's let's try to do that again
that's the conservative way it's not
just live and let live man
it's not just hey you don't like us
anymore let's just split up the country
you can have california we'll have texas
it is no this is this is a country
if we start splitting up the country now
it's going to end with 330 million
different countries
okay it's going to end everyone's going
to split texas is going to split into
then it's going to split in four then
it's going to split in 16 and it's just
going to keep going on that way anytime
anyone has a disagreement because no
one's going to have the guts in the hood
spend the vision to rule and so that's
it and then we'll just have a zillion
countries and then china will invade and
that's it
no or
we're going to rule the country i love
sarah silverman gives a very good
analogy here she says it's like when
people are in a relationship and they
don't like each other they split up
but now a country is not like your
middle school girlfriend okay it's not
like your middle school relationship
it's not just like well one month you're
dating this person in the next month
you're dating that person
a country is like a marriage
and i know that there are many liberals
and libertarians today who believe look
if you don't like your wife just leave
her just split if you guys aren't having
fun
have a no fault divorce just split it's
no big deal all that matters is pursuing
your own pleasure
that's not the conservative view of
things
if you if you are having trouble in your
marriage fix your marriage how about if
you're having trouble with your marriage
how about you lead your household
how about that crazy i know you're not
allowed to suggest that anymore but i
think that would be the right thing to
do
a national divorce is not only
impossible i don't think it generally
works but if
e
implausible at least but if if there
were to be such a thing people would die
and there would be lots of messy ugly
things and we would not be allies we
would almost inevitably go to war
the country did try to split one time
didn't turn out very well
and
and that would be that so are you really
are you really willing to go out and
shoot your neighbor over some so because
i'm not
not yet anyway i don't think we are at
the point where we need an actual split
an actual civil war i don't think we
should do that i think we should just
have a nation
and insist upon over the
protestations of not just libertarians
but the liberal ruling class we need to
insist upon a nation with national unity
with a vision of the good that is not
evil and actually just do it and insist
upon borders and deport foreigners and
have standards and enforce those
standards and actually have a good
country that's what we need to do
i know it's the most radical solution of
all is actually have a country
the left the answer to leftist
predations
is not to split
it is to beat
the left think about this we talk about
abortion they say okay so half the
country wants to kill babies half the
country doesn't want to kill babies so
let's just split
so hold on your answer
your answer to half the country's
killing a million babies a year is
let them do it
that's not my answer even
far short of killing babies
right now there are videos going around
of the left forcing cute little kids to
wear masks for absolutely no reason
whatsoever other than their own
enforcement of of their authority
they're forcing these masks on these
little kids
and our answer is what we're just going
to let them do it i don't think so
a video has gone viral of a daycare
worker
forcing a little
kid i don't know how old is this kid two
or three years old
to wear
a face mask
[Music]
there you go keep it right there
yay
[Music]
[Music]
i can't watch anymore
that woman who is doing this should not
only be fired she should be in a just
society she would be arrested tried and
banished so to some pacific island as
far away from civilization as possible
this is insane behavior
one we know
statistically from the data that
children are very very very very very
very very very unlikely
to face any serious consequences of the
coronavirus
now if you're saying well the kid has to
wear the mask to protect the adults we
know we were just told that the vaccines
are extremely effective at preventing
the people who receive the vaccines from
facing serious consequences from
coronavirus presumably all of those
adults have had the vaccine and if they
won't get the vaccine then surely the
answer to protecting themselves is not
to muzzle up a little kid who doesn't
even know what's going on that's sick
that is sick behavior that's sick people
in a very sick country doing very sick
things
the answer to that is not well let the
libs do whatever they want oh well live
and let live gosh i'm going to avoid new
york huh let's just split the country
now the answer is hold these people to
account
and pass laws about not that that's the
actual way that we're really governed
much anymore by passing laws it's
usually through some random agency
actually that's where the vaccine
mandate's coming from some random
unaccountable executive agency
but do what you can wield political
power in such a way that that kind of
behavior is illegal and that when people
do it they face consequences for it
offer a standard offer a political
vision and then have the guts have the
have the spine to actually enforce it
this is something conservatives
you know even in the sort of
freewheeling last few decades where
they've lost a lot of their political
mind
sometimes they'll still hit on the right
policy the problem is they've been
they've had their brains so turned to
soup by by shallow
libertarian slogans or neoconservative
slogans that they refuse to actually
enforce anything well it would be wrong
for us to tell that daycare worker that
you can't muzzle the little kid why is
that wrong well you know
you even heard this from some people on
the abortion issue
well look i oppose abortion because i
don't think it's good to kill babies but
i would never impose my view on others
well why not you impose your view on
murder laws on some murder laws at least
you impose your view on traffic laws you
impose your view on rent laws
you impose your view on laws against
theft during
sometimes i guess before blm riots start
it up
so why not
why what is the hold up here what is the
hold up here
it doesn't make a lot of sense speaking
of
the american empire and
the ways in which we
so now abuse people this is a real
heightening of
this it's a story it's not getting a lot
of traffic in the establishment media
the united states droned
what it held to be a terrorist
but then it turned out actually it
wasn't a terrorist that we droned it was
a an aid worker in afghanistan then it
turned out it wasn't just an aid worker
it was an aid worker and two other
adults
in in the aid workers family and then it
turned out oh it actually wasn't just an
aid worker in the two other adults it
was an aid worker and two other adults
and seven kids
seven kids
now i i know
that in war
there is collateral damage this is one
of the arguments for being a little more
circumspect when we go to war
a little more reticent to actually go
and invade countries and hold them as
territories
seven kids if you have ever had a kid
think about it
the child is conceived
then you get very excited you wait nine
months you know you start getting little
baby clothes and things like that and
then the baby is born and then it takes
the mother a little while to recover and
then the baby's up only remember the
baby's up all night nursing and then you
raise the baby and you know he's getting
a little older takes his first little
steps and all these big milestones and
then you do that again and again
and again
and again
and again
and again
and then
some drone blows up your entire family
puts it a little bit more into
perspective
the uh
the adults are back in charge though
you didn't hear these stories from
donald trump i'm not i'm not going to
say it
you know you know what i'm not going to
say
right you know the thing that every
pundit says
on the conservative side when something
like that you know i'm not i don't i
will not say
if the situation was reversed
well if that you know if this were if
this were donald trump who did this if
this because
because we all know that because we all
know that doesn't matter
the
reality
of of what the biden administration has
done
just with this one case
this one family of 10 that the biden the
biden administration just blew up
even more than that the way the press
has handled it shows you something
that may be even more chilling than the
biden administration blowing up a family
in afghanistan
namely
the way our political system really
works
every tiny little story real or imagined
that can in any way be
ginned up into a scandal under a
republican will be and that's especially
true if the republican is actually a
threat to the liberal establishment
then they'll impeach him over a phone
call with ukraine
and the democrats can just blow up whole
families with seven kids and the
democrats can bust open our borders and
the democrats can abuse children and
mutilate children and kill children and
that's just completely fine that's the
reality of the political situation we're
in which is why we need
actual conservatives with actual
political vision and
as important as anything courage
spine
to actually enforce a political vision
to
stop it
this
political battle that we think is just
one side versus the other side and we
win sometimes it's not even close to
what the reality of the political
situation is we are up against leviathan
and we need real tough guys with real
vision and real clarity to be able to do
it i'm michael nolsas the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borin our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pawel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021 on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show